okay yeah let's uh let's run this clip
about the new American identity which is
something I think that we all care
deeply about
we hunger to be part of something bigger
than ourselves yet we cannot even answer
the question of what it means to be an
American
today the woke left preys on that vacuum
they tell you that your race your gender
and your sexual orientation govern who
you are what you can achieve and what
you're allowed to think
this is psychological slavery and that
has created a new Culture of Fear in our
country that has completely replaced our
culture of free speech in America
and that is why today I am announcing my
run for president of the United States
there he is he's uh about to join us yes
we're going to be talking about
psychological slavery we're going to be
talking about uh what it means to be an
American
whether or not uh Vivek ramaswavi eats
pudding with his fingers like Ron
DeSantis allegedly does or does he use a
spoon or a fork four fingers is what uh
apparently is four fingers now you know
what two fingers if you're confident I
think it's two fingers three fingers
you're on the edge four fingers it's
yeah
just not Canada oh
all right
it's going to be a good conversation
thanks everybody who joined us we got 90
people watching concurrently according
to uh
all right um there he is Vivek ramaswamy
thanks so much for joining the reason
live stream it's good to be on I'm sorry
to be finishing half of the lunch here
as I grabbed a bike walking in as long
as it's the second half you know uh it
was so it was a couple bites you were a
busy man we just we uh introduced uh you
a bit uh uh a couple minutes ago and uh
we ran part of your presidential
announcement where you talked about how
people in America want to be part of
something bigger uh but we don't have uh
and that the way the left and wokeness
is kind of working it's a form of
psychological slavery you mentioned in
your um in your announcement uh that we
don't even know what it means to be an
American anymore
um I'm gonna let you finish that sip of
water and then launch into like what
what for you what does it mean to be an
American uh right now
well that is the conversation we need to
be having in the country that's the
entire premise of this campaign is it is
a cultural movement
to revive our missing national identity
to me
being an American means you believe in
the principles that set the nation into
motion 250 years ago principles like the
rule of law that people like my parents
yes do get to come here legally if they
come through the front door but that
your First Act of entering this country
by definition cannot be a law-breaking
one if you believe in the rule of law as
the basis of your national identity I
think it
means you believe in basic ideas like
free speech and open debate as our
mechanism for settling political
questions not the use of force and yet
today we live in a God we can go into
the details of how I don't think we're
up to that national identity but your
question is what does it mean to be an
American I think it means the two of you
get to speak your mind freely as long as
I get to in return and the same goes for
our neighbors do we uh would you be in
favor of increasing legal immigration
increasing decreasing is The Wrong
conversation it with due respect okay I
think I am in favor of merit-based
immigration and I can Define what that
means but if that results in a higher
number or a lower number I'm fine with
that but that's the standard we have to
apply what's uh what's merit-based uh
immigration some air-based immigration I
think there's two components to Merit I
think in as at least immigration
one is your actual ability to make
contributions to this country
economically particularly in areas where
we could use great contributions keep in
mind one of the one of the great
obstacles to GDP growth in America today
is a Workforce shortage actually as a
worker shortage problem let's just cabin
that away or somewhere immigration can
play a role in alleviating that but it
also means that you Embrace Civic
commitments to the country that you
actually understand the history of this
country the Constitution I want to
ratchet that up and then I actually want
to bring that back to high school
students and we can talk about Reviving
the notion of capital c citizenship not
just for people who come from abroad but
even people who age into citizenship I
think that's something we don't talk
enough about but anyway you are Ohio
born and bred right
I lived in Oxford Ohio part-time and
full-time for 20 years I know Ohio is
the heart of it all you know every fast
food chain is headquartered in Columbus
it seems with the exception of
McDonald's and who needs them
I want to ask just a real quick question
about the Merit or the the immigration
that made America what it is my
grandparents from Ireland but especially
from Italy emigrated here in the mid 19
teens they were illiterate they were
uneducated they never learned to speak
English they worshiped a strange God
using Latin there's no way people like
that would have made it in under any
kind of America system uh yet they came
here and they contributed I would say
mightily to America
um so I guess my question is you know is
Merit simply a another word for getting
you know H-1B visa workers in short
supply uh who with degrees in and where
does that leave you know Mexicans who
want to come here and will cook the food
and clean the you know clean the diapers
uh both older and Young Americans of Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden's you know
children who are living in the white
house now where where does that leave
the immigrants who came here on mass
without really anything to offer other
than they you know they were coming here
to be set free to work
so I'd say a couple of things first of
all I think there are different phases
that a country goes through right now
we're coming off of a period where we
have had rampant illegal immigration in
the country we need to actually be
stringent we've also lost our national
identity I don't think that has been
true for most of our national history I
don't think that it will be true for
much of our national future but I think
that I'm running for president in the
year 2024 and this is what I what I
Advanced for the year 2024. another
thing I'll say is that Merit means more
than just having a bunch of tech skills
I'm not sure that we have the dearth of
engineers in this country and by the way
you brought the H-1B visa system that is
so broken I mean we actually we're
afraid to make decisions based on Merit
and we have an H1B we have a Visa
Lottery systems actually why on Earth
would you leave it to chance when you
could actually just meritocratically
pick what we actually need now you talk
about people there's there's many
shortages in this country we have a
shortage of plumbers of Carpenters of
welders we have a shortage of people
Healthcare assistance
people in and out of beds we have a
rampant we have a Orca shortage in
multiple sectors of the economy Silicon
Valley is the least of the problem and
so when I say Merit I meant what I said
make contributions to to the country
especially in areas where we are short
on people to make those contributions we
also used to have a system in this
country I think is a reasonable
conversation to have about it of people
who actually want to come here as
seasonal workers and then to go back to
South the border Mexico as part of a
legally ordained process I think that
there's reasonable room for that being
part of the conversation about
merit-based immigration too why do you
think Republicans in particular and you
know liberals have not been particularly
pro-immigrant but Republicans right now
the Republican party is hostile to
immigrants legal and illegal in general
Donald Trump I don't know if I agree
with that assertion I think Donald Trump
was pro-immigrant in absolutely no way
shape or form right Ron DeSantis is not
talking about you know increasing legal
immigration or make it easier for good
people to move here Rhonda Sanders just
says whatever he thinks the political
base wants to hear in a given moment he
doesn't have independent of it thoughts
of his own he responds to Twitter and
the effects of it
um so I don't know what Rhonda Sanders
thinks I just know what comes out of his
mouth reflects what he thinks is going
to achieve that dopamine hit in getting
a Twitter Trend but I I'm not sure I
agree that that's where most Republicans
are here's where here's what I see on
the ground I mean when I speak to
Grassroots audiences I think they're
hungry for leadership on this and
they're very open-minded I think part of
the reason that the likes of Ron
DeSantis get mistaken into thinking the
Republican bases against immigration is
that the way that higher-ups in the
party talk about this conflates border
security with immigration those are two
different issues border security is
border security immigration is
immigration and so I think this is one
of the areas where I'm not afraid to
draw contrast with those who either
haven't developed their positions or
those who have adopted a position that's
grounded in I think a backlash to border
security where I'm I'm a hard-liner
there believe me I think I believe in
using our military to secure our own
border I think legitimate use of the
military to actually you know combine
that with building a wall I think it's
what it means to live in a nation built
on the rule of law
but I am completely
a fan of legal merit-based immigration I
think we should embrace it can breathe
both the economic and Civic lifeblood
back into the country and that's not a
bunch of tech Bros in Silicon Valley
that is really looking at need more
broadly in a way that we can actually
sensibly bring people into the country
and I think many in our base including
the conservative base in the Republican
Party are with us it's just that you
have Stooges at the top uh you know
professional politicians it's not just
Rhonda Sanders he's just one of them who
think they're responding to what the
base wants jumping like a circus monkey
without actually having independent
thoughts about what our actual
principles really are to follow up on
the Ron DeSantis question the Rhonda
Sanchez topic you know he is someone who
like you has put the sort of fight
against so-called corporate wokeness on
the front burner uh he is fighting this
battle with Disney right now in Florida
if that is kind of at the center of both
of your campaigns why should people opt
for you or take a closer look at you
versus you know a popular two-term
governor in Florida
so the popular two-time governor in
Florida has been good as an executor in
certain respects not as good as he would
make it out to be but I think that's a
that's a separate discussion for another
day
the question is who do you want in the
white house do you want a Visionary who
has their own ideas or do you want a guy
who executes other people's ideas and I
think there's a role for everyone in the
system but I think when we're in the
middle of this national identity crisis
in our country I don't think we want a
follower in the in the white house I
think we need an independent thinker and
a leader and the case I make for
Effectiveness too is that Rhonda said
this is like a billiard ball you hit him
in a given Direction he'll go in that
direction
but he doesn't know why he's heading in
that direction he's not the one doing
the aiming and that results in loss of
Effectiveness so let's just take the
Disney thing for example right the real
root cause of what causes many companies
to behave in the way they do
it's a complex story I literally have a
book out this week that that lays out
part of that cause well we're going to
talk in depth about capitalist
punishment yes
I mean and I'm you know I don't write
these books to sell books I care about
spreading a message so forget about that
but I'm getting complain about Rhonda
sanus that's what the Upstream causes
for a lot of corporate wokism he's
instead using the bully pulpit of the
state to score some points on social
media and conservative media but missing
the point where what he says he is doing
it's laughable is that he's rolling back
the special protections that Disney
shouldn't have been given in the first
place I I I agree with that I don't like
chronic capitalism I don't like special
forms of corporate protections that are
the product of lobbying what the media
completely missed it shows you how to
sleep at the switch even the media is
is that some of those corporate
Privileges and special protections were
signed into law just a couple of years
ago by wait for it Ron DeSantis actually
and I can go into the details of what
those were those included exemptions
from the political anti-discrimination
statute that he passed there was a
special exemption if you own a theme
park more than 25 acres in the State of
Florida that was signed by Governor Ron
DeSantis and then he strips that after
the fact saying that oh we should have
never had these chronic capitalist
Protections in the first place that's a
joke because he was actually the one of
the ones who signed it in the first
place anyhow and so I think that that
state action
um you know argument or that lurking
State action piece I think is is a bit
of a farce and I think that you know I
think that he ruins the credibility of
his own Crusade by not knowing why he
was doing in the first place and by the
way Disney then gets the better of him
in the end by the day before his new
governing board takes over completely
castrating that board of having any
power so execution's missing same thing
I mean divesting from BlackRock he'll
have a nice little Twitter Trend
removing 700 million dollars yet that's
mostly cash and short-term Securities
when they have a 13 billion dollar
pension fund that's still invested with
BlackRock
I think what happens is you repeatedly
Miss by half when you don't know why
you're going through the motions but
you're just going through them or you're
going through them because Twitter you
know told you to and gave you dopamine
hit and made you think that that's what
you're supposed to do as opposed to
having first principles I think that's
what's missing it's fine for a governor
who can do a decent job but if you're
looking for the next U.S president to
lead us out of a national identity
crisis I think it's going to take more
than Ron DeSantis and I say this as
somebody who for a long time squinted
and tried to see it and tried to get
excited decided that it was it was fake
in me to do that as well and by the way
if you don't have somebody who's willing
to go to a college campus Because the
questions haven't been pre-vetted he's
afraid of 22 year olds if you're not
going to sit across the table from Chuck
Todd at NBC as I'm doing this Sunday I
Meet the Press and Rhonda sanus says he
won't talk to NBC because they're not
nice to him
you're not fit to sit across the table
from Xi Jinping representing you uh
would you uh arm wrestle Ron DeSantis if
he agreed to sit down with you I
probably would yeah why not
let's you know we took uh we're taking a
chance wheeler and I have reason are
taking chance because the last two big
talk shows that you appeared on was Don
Lemon on CNN and Tucker Carlson and they
both were fired you know hours after
appearing on uh uh having you as a guest
um to talk about this identity crisis
and about kind of bringing people
together can we run let's run that uh
clip Zach that you have of the Don Lemon
discussion because I think this comes to
bear on these questions of national
identity Vivek and what you're putting
at the at the foreground of your
um presidential run so let's look at
this clip real quick and let me just
note that this is uh you know edited
down for time but we have the links to
everything in the description
we fought a Civil War in this country to
give black Americans the equal
protection under the law that we failed
to secure them in 1776. but then you
want to know what happened Southern
States passed anti-gun laws that stopped
black people from owning guns the
Democrat Party then as in now wanted to
put them back in chains that war was not
fought for black people to have guns
that's that's not that war was brought
for black people to have freedoms in
this country actually that's why the
Civil War was fought okay
for black people to have guns I think
actually you know funny fact is black
people did not get to enjoy the other
freedoms until their second amendment
rights were secured and I think that
that's one of the lessons that we aren't
allowed to enjoy the freedoms I disagree
with you on that Don I disagree with you
on it I think you're doing a disservice
to our country by failing to recognize
the fact that we have these and and you
live in this country then you can
disagree with me but we're not well
here's where you and I have a different
point of view I think we should be able
to expressed our views regardless of the
color of our skin we should have this
debate without me regarding you as a
black man insulting that you're
regarding you as a fellow citizen here
whatever ethnicity you are explaining to
me what it's like to be black whatever
ethnicity what I am I'm an Indian
American I'm proud of it but I think we
should have this debate black white
doesn't matter I think we should have
this content of the idea do it you
should do it in an honest way
uh and let's note that uh according to
the New York Times this might have been
one of the last straws for Don Lemon
they uh right here that the incident
left several CNN leaders exasperated so
just before we get into the substance of
your disagreement with Don Lemon there
what's your reaction to his dismissal
I mean look I think that depends on the
mission of your organization if the
mission of your organization is to
foster a particular worldview in this
case a woke world view and to advance
that that's a perfectly legitimate we
live in a free country you're allowed to
start an Enterprise where that's your
purpose Don Lemon would make a great
host but if your State admission of your
organization is what Chris licked the
new CEO of CNN says their mission is is
to Foster diverse viewpoints and
actually engage in the prevance of news
and opinions that are diverse in nature
on your programs then Don Lemon would
not be a good host if he shouts down
guests on the base of the color of their
skin saying they can't make those
arguments and you didn't have the
segment where he was also shouting it as
producers and preventing as a co-host
from getting into the conversation so it
depends on what the mission of your
organization is CNN has stated its
missions I think it would be very
consistent with that mission for them to
find a better Anchor than Don Lemon so
I'm happy to have played the final role
in squeezing uh the lemonade out of the
lemon and and you know moving on with it
so I think more debates what we need and
and by the way can I ask you a question
yeah this is a live stream that you guys
do right yes you also put it out as a
podcast or is it just a live stream yeah
I like this live stream model right do
you take questions from people too or
where yes we do we have a goal we get no
audience questions in a little bit as
well
I love it in that clip the way that
Poppy Harlow the co-host starts reading
her phone because she's like totally I'm
not gonna get involved with this
um the reason I asked that the reason I
asked that about your guys's thing is
that's different about cable TV as a
medium that would have been kind of fun
actually to get like audience reactions
during the middle of that and instead I
just saw you know poppy look very
uncomfortable and this that's all the
reaction we had yeah it might be a
generational thing as well I mean that
you know what has happened broadly
Across America Western of the world is
that power differentials have been
leveled and equalized by things like the
internet and you know cable news which
at one time was New Media is now old
media and it's not used to kind of the
back and forth yeah I think the world
younger people in general or newer forms
of technology really enable or kind of
uh demand
um what is your what's your pitch to
Black America
um though because you know most blacks
are you know blacks the the share of
black votes that went to the GOP went up
a little bit under Trump in the second
term but you know basically since
Eisenhower in his second term you know
it's rare when a when a republican
candidate can get 10 of the black vote
um you know what's your pitch to Black
America and you're asking about for a
new national identity yeah so the first
thing I would say is I don't view there
as being one Black America just like
there's no one white America or one
Indian American America I reject that
premise at the outset but you know how
why do we take a look at this
demographic that tends to vote Democrat
I think a big part of the problem is
Republicans have not explained what our
intentions are and I say our I mean I'm
I'm an America First conservative I am
using the Republican party as a vehicle
to advance my set of ideals I'm very
open about that I'm not a partisan
politician or hack I could care less for
political partisanship most of it bores
me but we're playing the game of
presidential politics let's talk about
the Republican Party
I think let's look at the facts I mean
Lyndon Johnson created a so-called Great
Society it's the biggest misnomer in
modern political history that wasn't a
very great society for the very black
people it was supposed to help
paid mothers government money to have an
incentive to get the dad out of the
house so they could make more money
Uncle Sam's better for me than you over
here maybe I'll marry him instead so how
you get to over 70 of black kids being
born into two parent households in the
1960s to less than 30 percent today you
get what you pay for is the answer to
that and I think it's in a front I don't
think that's been good for black
Americans across the country it isn't it
also true the breeze I mean you know and
I I'm thinking of somebody like Jackie
Robinson who in 1960 campaigned for
Richard Nixon in 1964 campaigned for
Democrats because Republicans voted
against the Civil Rights Act and the
Voting Rights Act of the mid-60s when
much of the country was still under
legal segregation where it was illegal
to serve blacks and whites equally it
was illegal for blacks to go to certain
schools and things like that and it
strikes me as you know kind of if you
start the clock in 1968 or 1972 it's one
thing but
um you know this I mean I think this is
part of Republican problem with an
appeal to Black Americans is that yeah I
mean that's ancient history at this
point it is literally if you're talking
about you know Lyndon Johnson you know
we're talking about the 60s
fair enough you know I I was talking
about Lyndon Johnson because many of
those policies are still in effect today
right Civil Rights Act did pass and
there's broad consensus in favor of the
Civil Rights Acts today I think that
there's there should not be in my
opinion broad consensus around the
vestiges of Lyndon Johnson's Great
Society so that's the distinction I draw
I mean the Republican party is the party
that was the Abolitionist party and the
pro in the post Reconstruction Era also
wanted to put guns in the household of
black Americans so they could actually
secure the civil rights as I was talking
about in that clip so go back to him and
these parties like I said these labels
mean very little if you go far enough
back party's a flip-flop but what I say
is that the policies I care about want
to go to the root causes restore the
nuclear family structure as a cultural
norm in this country including in Black
America restore focus on education
school choice is a big part of this
empowering many black families that are
trapped in ghetto-like communities for
their kids to be trapped in those
schools and I use that word
intentionally to provoke the point that
we're really confining people to the
public school systems where they live
without school choice programs Democrats
are the ones who are opposed to school
choice programs right was the most
pro-school Choice president in history
the federal government I was obviously
plays a limited role in education why
would you be better than Donald Trump
who is your you know who is the leading
Republican candidate uh former president
himself former businessman why are you
better than Donald Trump I I think he
was going to take the America First
agenda about as far as he was going to
go I'm now taking it further and taking
on issues that Trump was frankly I think
a little bit reluctant to touch take
affirmative action the U.S president can
end affirmative action also started
under Lyndon Johnson by an executive
order
Trump could have ended by an executive
order I pushed his people on why they
didn't do it they said it was a
political Hill they did not want to die
on I have no such fears or inhibitions
I'll take that on I'll I'll do it on day
one easy thing to do one one two four
six put into motion by Lyndon Johnson
we'll take a pen and cross it out I
reject the climate cult I will issue an
executive order saying that we're done
measuring or mandating carbon emissions
measurements through any Vector of the
federal government
it's a longer discussion but I think
it's based on fraudulent premises and so
so I'll get that done you know I think
that shutting you're talking about the
Department of Education yes he put a
good person on top of it Betsy DeVos
well the way I view it is that
government agency should have never
existed in the first place I'll shut it
down I've identified a list of
government agencies that I would
actually literally shut down so I'm
going further than Trump but here's the
thing
I think we'll also unify the country as
we do it and I know that sounds
counterintuitive I'm going further than
Trump on America first but also uniting
the country yes is the answer because if
we're doing it based on first principles
and moral Authority rather than
Vengeance and grievance
that is the path to National Unity a
national Revival rather than a national
divorce I don't think we get to National
Unity by showing up in the proverbial
middle
and saying let's all compromise and hold
hands and sing Kumbaya I think we get to
National Unity by embracing
the radicalism
of the American ideals that bind us
together across our diversity
and that's what I'm doing in a way that
I think the last president who actually
tied the agenda to the why to those
principles was actually Ronald Reagan I
think that's why Reagan was more
successful than Trump I think he was
actually in driving a national Revival
your your plant platform is called
America First 2.0 uh we'll have a link
in the show notes to uh so people can
run through it you mentioned getting rid
of the Department of Education a bunch
of other alphabet agencies one of them
is the FBI what is your argument you
know this is a Libertarian audience so
you've already you know you had us at F
but what is your case against
dismantling the FBI and what would you
replace it with if anything yeah this is
FBI IRS ATF Alcohol Tobacco Firearms
nuclear Regulatory Commission we've
identified and I'm not doing this glibly
right because you know there's agencies
we can just list the whole thing we've
studied and understood what we're going
to do with each one the Department of
Education should have never existed in
the first place we're shutting that down
the FBI look as long as you're going to
have federal laws you need a federal law
enforcement apparatus but that's in a
different category as is the IRS as long
as you have taxes which I'm not a big
fan of but as long as you have taxes you
need somebody to collect them so be it
the problem they're slightly different
you have
a cultural Corruption of those
institutions that runs so deep that I
believe it will be impossible to reform
top down or any other way it's part of
the rot of the Beast it is the Leviathan
itself is ossified
and so I think they're the only right
answer is you shut it down and then you
built something skeletal from scratch to
take its place that actually respects
the Constitution rather than viewing it
as an inconvenience and it's the same
FBI that corruptly denied Martin Luther
King Jr in this country a concealed
carry permit that now politicizes
another Direction so if you look at the
area under the curve over the last 60
years this would actually be a
bipartisan consensus it's just that
Republicans and Democrats would have
supported it at different times so I'm
getting a job done that we should have
gotten done 60 years ago it's literally
still the J Edgar Hoover building in
Washington DC that those employees walk
into it's J Edgar Hoover's FBI even
though the guy's long gone and I'll shut
it down and I think that that's
something I'm taking on without apology
the other thing before I forget it guys
is which is because we were having uh
you know meeting about the debate stage
and everything else is the way I get on
the debate stage and and get to the
center of the debate stage is actually
one of the attributes is unique donor
counts so if people like and agree you
don't have to agree with everything I'm
saying but if you believe and you don't
even have to know you're gonna vote for
me but if you believe this set of ideas
we can drive that on the Republican
debate stage just like I took it to the
debate stage with Don Lemon
if you want to see these ideas at the
Forefront of the GOP see Ron DeSantis
and Donald Trump and others answer to it
and us actually sharpening what the GOP
actually stands for interesting question
there
help me do it I think literally
everybody
right now I'm going to be craving about
it we're not about raising money you
know I'm not opposed to that right but
we're talking about unique donor counts
that's one of the key metrics they've
they've actually recently identified
give one dollar what are you going to do
about
the uh suggestion yeah I mean trust me
anybody who sees this will know where to
find you and give you money and yeah can
I just return to the the alphabet
agencies for a second there because for
Libertarians another group that we tend
to worry about are the national security
agencies the NSA the CIA the DHS and
talk about lawlessness
um and the kind of you know un the
unwinding we've seen of our foreign
policy in general in terms of you know
both covert and overt operations
totally what is your general take on
kind of that National Security apparatus
and just it is corrupt National Defense
okay it is corrupt it's fundamentally
corrupt and you know I think I mean even
recently you don't have to look to
ancient history for this I think it's
appalling that we have a media that will
focus on the mechanics of a leak and how
to prosecute some basically kid who
leaked some material and I'm not
condoning that but
what about focusing on the substance of
the leak that we actually have troops on
the ground in Ukraine which is in a war
with Russia right without telling the
American people not only without telling
what lying about it right and this has
just been a habitual pattern in our
national security establishment it is
corrupt get rid of you get rid of the
Pentagon too you built afterwards well
I'm not going to be glib I mean I've
I've studied the agencies that were that
were we've identified to shut down and I
mean it when I say we will shut them
down and what we and the ones we'll
rebuild and the ones we won't
um you know I I have a very I'll
certainly drain the managerial class at
the Pentagon that much I'll go without
saying but I'm I'm not going to just
give you a glib answer I'm not Ron
DeSantis okay I'm not just gonna say
something because I think it's going to
impress you and then and then you just
screw it up later what is it here's what
I will say massive reform is needed the
managerial class runs the show at the
Pentagon that much is clear how we go
about draining it that's a beast we're
gonna have to look at how we take on I
think someone I think I'm also going to
send a signal and set some tone here I'm
looking actually you know the campaign
Trail is so busy but I want to make a
trip out to the UK I want to visit
Julian Assange I expect to Pardon Julian
Assange I think the fact that the fact
that Chelsea Manning got a sentence
commuted by President Obama but without
Julian Assange the person who actually
just published the information that was
leaked I just think this is this just
reeks of the rot that is the
administrative police state disguised in
the Garb of Nationals what about uh
people like uh uh Edward Snowden or
Daniel Hale also are they Patriots or
are they truth tellers or are they
treason uh so I would say I mean I have
a long and growing pardon list I mean
the likes of Douglas Mackey right who's
facing 10 years in prison now for making
a meme about Hillary Clinton supporters
on the internet this is not the country
we live in right so here's where I am on
the store I think I actually actually
think he did do an important national
service I'm thinking through that part
Julian Assange I'm on firm footing on
because he's a journalist he's somebody
who literally posted
the stuff he was given that's just how
the free press works this is a selective
prosecution you know the thing with
Snowden is part of what might make it
honorable is he took the risk and and
the knowing risk of actually
you know he violated the law right and
so I believe in the rule of law that's a
tougher case for me as I'm thinking
through that but that's not something
I'm going to make a commitment on right
now but Julian Assange I I have thought
through and made a commitment on that
shouldn't it exactly well with Assange
you know what he is what they're going
have gone after him for posting or
working with uh Chelsea Manning to post
where these videos from uh you know uh
military operations in Afghanistan uh
basically uh one involved the kind of
gunning down of a photojournalist
I'm curious you know as a you you say
you're continuing the America First
agenda and part of that what Trump shook
up within the Republican party was
foreign policy and rethinking the role
of American Military might where we
should and shouldn't be in the world
what are your thoughts on American
foreign policy interventionism I think
it has been disastrously expansive and I
think that we should actually have
leaders who are able to lead with
authority diplomatically using our
economic might and the backstop of
military strength yes but economic might
is part of it's part of what we've also
lost
to lead diplomatically and also some of
this is first personal I mean who the
leader is it's not just some system
first personal leadership actually
matters we're not doing enough of that
certainly under Biden but we're
substituting for it by sending U.S
military capabilities to places like
Ukraine and and you know I I've been
pretty clear about this I would not send
another dollar to Ukraine in fact I
think it's in a front that we now
discover that we have American troops on
the ground in Ukraine so I think
intervention in parts of the world where
we have no direct National interest has
been a disaster I plot Trump for
actually defecting from a bipartisan
consensus around that for much of the
last 20 years he deserves credit for
that now I'm looking in other respects
to take the agenda much further than
Trump did to do it based on principles
but I want to recognize that was a
positive development in our foreign
policy as I see it and I intend to
continue uh that course on Donald Trump
uh you know Don Lemon got in trouble a
couple weeks ago when Nikki Haley
announcing she was Pastor Prime because
she was in her I guess early 50s as
woman Donald Trump is going to be like
78 you know he's an old man is Donald
Trump past his prime
well it's funny Joe Biden and Donald
Trump will literally be more than twice
there they are literally more than twice
my age and then some but
these people that says just because
you're old you know you're disqualified
or whatever I I think this is another
form of cheap identity politics I know a
lot of people who are not a lot but some
who are older than Joe Biden and sharper
than many people my age right so that
happens too
I think that the question is how far was
he gonna go and I think he did most of
what he was going to do he went about as
far as he was going to go
I think that you can go further if we're
actually doing it on principled footing
rather than just Vengeance and grievance
that's to be the fuel that takes you so
far one principles can take you further
and I'll tell you this I'll tell you
this too actually this is just true it
relates to your question a little more
closely I won't be the same person eight
years from now if I'm in the white house
for the next 10 years for the next eight
years plus the year and a half the
campaign that's left I won't be the same
person then that I am today just as
Trump isn't the same person that he was
right in 2015 right you get to be an
outsider once this time I've got fresh
legs you know I've got I'm not jaded and
cynical yet I'm not tired and defeated
yet and so you know you take the
tourists you patch it on the next guy
who's able to take it further and and I
expect to do the same when I'm leaving
office as well I think that's the way
you know uh what's your role for
national debt and you know debt is a
problem and deficit spending or
borrowing constantly depresses long-term
economic growth the flood of cheap money
and fake money obviously is a major
cause if not the major cause of
inflation we have a massive and ongoing
debt problem we have unsustainable old
age entitlements you know all of the
budget we're approaching 70 percent of
the federal budget is basically for
Medicare and Social Security these have
trust funds that are going bust in the
near future uh what is your plan to
alter old age entitlements uh and bring
government spending and revenue into
some kind of uh you know Accord well the
top low-hanging fruit is what nobody in
either party's talking about which
amazes me which is actually GDP growth
itself it's as though we've forgotten
that's an option and all of those
projections that say we're going to run
out of money assume you know fairly
enough I guess the current GDP growth
rate and if you extrapolate that out yes
we're going bust economic you know
financially and fiscally seeking it
doesn't have to be that way we've grown
at more than four plus percent GDP
growth for most of our national history
if we get back to a three-handle three
point something actually most of those
fiscal problems are completely gone on
now that doesn't mean that I don't favor
more discipline in our spending but I'm
just talking about more hanging fruit
here no no but wait lower hanging fruit
being economic growth that's kind of
crazy talking because it's not I'll tell
you why okay but I'm just saying in the
21st century we've had lower than
average percent annual uh GDP growth uh
before that for the 50 years before that
it was more like three percent most
advanced economies have also seen bad
economic growth so how are you going to
conjure that out of a hat and I don't
think anybody you know the one thing we
can control is government spending right
not whether or not the economy grows or
not well actually I think that I think
that that's a much I mean we do have a
constitutional system of self-governance
that let me challenge you back if it was
going to be so easy why haven't we done
it I think we actually lacked political
consensus and social consensus around
the commitments we've historically made
so if that was so easy it would happen
now let me tell you you could say the
same in Reverse to me about GDP growth
but you haven't had a president like me
let me tell you actually identifying
obstacles to GDP growth and then how
we're going to address them the number
one obstacle that's easily addressable
is unshackling the U.S energy sector
it's actually a fundamental input to the
rest of the economy we have put
ourselves in a straight jacket at behest
of this climate cult that shackles the
us while leaving China untouched I think
that's a big problem it's easily
solvable and I can go into detail about
how I would address it drill Frack burn
coal yes I know those are epithets
Embrace nuclear energy we can talk about
that too productivity drives GDP growth
productivity is in part driven by the
productivity of the American Energy
sector second thing is that we've talked
about the number one obstacle to many
businesses growing right now is the
worker shortage you get what you pay for
we subsidize for your gender studies
majors in California what ever without
actually what while putting at a
competitive disadvantage then
cultural and gender studies graduates
are 0.04 of all college graduates on a
manual basis that's not
right now
like I'm using an expression I'm using
an expression four-year college degrees
I I I I I just I think we have a
fundamental disagreement on how
achievable GDP growth can be I do not
share your defeated but I'm in the
middle of telling you how we're going to
do it so if I may and then you you I
didn't bring up gender studies
I'm stating a fact as we subsidize for
your college education which actually
subsidizes people taking on debt that
they shouldn't take on then the
government gets in a in a quick stand
where they have to say they relieve it
as opposed to which necessarily puts it
a competitive disadvantage it's just
definitionally a competitive
disadvantage somebody wants to pursue a
one-year program to be a builder a
mechanic a carpenter plumber well you
can't find a builder mechanic a
carpenter or plumber part of it's what
you get what you pay for part of it is
that Lyndon Johnson great society which
created a culture an anti-work culture
in this country
you know put on put that on supercharge
with the covid aid over the last couple
of years we have created a culture of
laziness in this country
because human beings are not economic
automatons so even after you strip back
some of that covered Aid people start to
form that habit so unshackling the
energy sector putting people back to
work and merit-based immigration plays a
role in that in the third
is reform of the Federal Reserve which
is fundamentally hostile so
let me ask you a question here uh
because um how interested are you in
this third topic because this will
require a minute to explain I think our
audience will be will be interested yes
okay because Nick you're cool too I just
want to make sure before I go yeah not
generally big fans of a uh uh loosened
baggy Fed so please okay so so this is a
fundamental obstacle to GDP growth in
the country this is something the
president can do so
what happened with the Federal Reserve
is I think it's not a coincidence that
when we went off the gold standard
actually before 1972 we actually were
growing at four four plus percent GDP
growth for most of our national history
we went off the gold standard we had a
Federal Reserve that still was nominally
including under volcker committed to
stabilizing the dollar as a unit of
measurement we still had three plus
percent GDP growth for the period you
know through the 80s 90s Etc
what happened is a bunch of academicians
took over the FED in the late 1990s in
under the mythology of this thing called
the Phillips curve I don't know if this
means something to you or not but okay I
mean is this myth that there's a
trade-off between inflation unemployment
centers yes some somebody can control
this it was based on Old New Zealand
data by a British Economist anyway
somehow America fellow American Federal
Reserve System fell in love with that
and figured that we have a financial God
that can balance inflation and
unemployment that's about the equivalent
of hitting two Targets with one Arrow
you can't do it and I think what's
happened then is that Federal Reserve
has taken on far more responsibility to
supposedly smooth out a business cycle
which they've actually exacerbated
so one of the things they do is they
take
what is a trailing indicator of the
business cycle wage growth in the
country and treat it like a leading
indicator what does that mean they
tighten because they treat wage growth
as a leading indicator of inflation when
in fact it's the last thing to go up in
the business cycle which means they
consistently tighten monetary policy
into a business cycle downturn which
gives us the 2008 financial crisis a big
part of the 2000 Tech Bubble Burst was
worsened by this and then also what
we're seeing even now happening in the
current current 2023 banking instability
so as president what do you do to
control fed policy because that fire
over 90 of the staff and put them back
to a mandate where they focus on
stabilizing the dollar as a unit of
measurement now here's what one of the
ways that affects GDP growth is you know
let's say the number of minutes in an
hour
floated okay and it varied and it was
volatile none of us would show up on
this live stream at the same time when
the dollars that volatile Capital does
not flow to the most efficient projects
that's an obstacle to GDP goes I think I
come back and just say no no don't be so
jaded GDP growth is located in your
fruit even politically and yet nobody's
talking about it I don't give up on that
and you know what I've
I've had you know I've I've lived the
life of building a successful career it
made up made I don't apologize for my
success a lot of money in the system of
free market American capitalism I have a
good handle on on how to on how to
actually accomplish I think it's
actually far more politically feasible
to abandon the climate called put people
back to work reform the Federal Reserve
and then we'll get spending cuts what
are the spending cuts concretely because
this is something that nobody ever wants
to talk about every you know even
Democrats will talk about cutting
wasteful spending but entitlements
Social Security Medicare what what has
to happen if anything to fix that so I'm
telling you what I'm going to do right
I'm not going to be there for more than
eight years in the eight years I'm there
I'm prioritizing GDP growth and then
shaving down the administrative State
there will be fewer than 25 percent of
the federal employees at the end of my
presidency than there will be on day one
that much I'm confident enough that
paves the way for the next guy to then
actually
take aim at much what that Federal
bureaucracy perpetuates now in a second
term maybe we return to that but I'm
being very clear about what I think
there will be broad consensus to get
done and here's why I'm focused on where
I am too I don't like to make false
promises why don't make false promises
everything I've told you or almost
everything I've told you can be done by
The Who would have ever thought the
office that I'm running for the U.S
president without asking Congress for
permission reform of the administrative
State shutting down government agencies
reform of the Federal Reserve all this
we're sending the executive order the
Creator affirmative action in America
draw a Common Thread through that the
things I'm telling you I'm going to do I
know I can tell you I'll do them because
I can do them without asking Congress
for permission that's the mistake that
most U.S presidents make because they
drive a legislative agenda throw a
little pop quiz back at you guys all
right uh what are you doing this how
long have you been doing this podcast by
the way uh since fall of 2016.
oh this makes this question very fair
game then
okay uh what was Trump's top
policy promise that he made
legislative promise you remember what it
was
uh uh I'm saying it's either that it was
going to be anti-political correctness
or that it was going to build a wall
yeah those were slogans but he had a
piece of legislation that he ran on
repeal and replace Obamacare okay right
now it was a pledge yeah it didn't work
out so well right yeah because Congress
stifles you so I'm keeping a clear head
on my shoulders I'm an executive I know
how to get things done I have a vision
for the country I think I can lead this
out of our national identity crisis with
the things a president and a president
alone can do without asking anybody for
permission or for forgiveness you know
uh
another one of Trump's slogans was he
was going to drain the Swap and that
kind of sounds like what you're saying
here is you're going to clear out the
dead wood get leaner and meaner um it
kind of relates to one of our audience
questions here from Brandon Brandon
Quinn who says how do you commit to
dismantling government agencies once
elected I'll just put a little twist on
that and say what are you going to do
differently from Trump who said that he
was going to come in you know Bannon his
advisor at the time was talking about
constructing the administrative state so
what strategic or political difference
um are or tack are you going to take
it's a couple of things I mean I think
the two main obstacles are one Civil
Service protections where the classic
advice is you can't fire people the
second is actually relates to what's
called impoundment prevention that you
have to spend money that Congress has
allocated let me start with the second
because that's what's generally viewed
by legal Scholars is the bigger obstacle
so there's a problem with the budgeting
process and here's how it works before
the way the Constitution envisioned it
there was three branches of government
not four the executive branch asked for
permission to spend money so the White
House would ask Congress for permission
to spend presidents started to get lazy
they delegated that after the birth of
the administrative state to say Hey you
agencies you know talk to Congress
directly or go through the OMB and talk
to Congress directly and make those
budget requests and Congress is lazy and
so they just started suggesting draft
language what the Deep State really
learned is that hey this is an
opportunity
what used to go as draft bills and
legislation for budgets as you may spend
X somehow started to come back as you
shall spendex because that's what the
administrative State wanted so then
let's say if Trump comes along and says
hey I want to you know this or that the
administrative State goes back and says
no no Mr President you can't do that
because Congress has said You shall
spend it simple solution I believe
there's one executive branch not two
it's called the unitary theory of the
executive
you'll need a fancy word to do it
there's three branches of government not
four
I think all about your requests will go
through the White House and we'll come
back with permission to spend which is
what the what the framers Envision but
that doesn't mean that I have to spend
it so I I can go through this the
language and the Civil Service stuff we
might put people to sleep but the point
is
you require two things to get this done
I think it's going to take an outside or
not somebody who's a creature of the
swamp and Trump was certainly an
outsider but it's going to be somebody
who has their own first personal bone
deep constitutional conviction to
actually see that through and I don't
think that existed in the Trump
Administration that's what I'm bringing
to the table is a com is a combination
of yeah I've written you know three
books in the last 18 months and a lot of
it's about constitutionalism and all
that I've also built multi-billion
dollar businesses and I'm not a
professional politician that's a unique
combination of attributes and speaking
as a member of my generation as I said
first Millennial candidate ever to run
as a republican I think that's going to
be a unique blend to see this through
the Leviathan will strike back I'm not
going to make it as easy as Trump did to
go after me that doesn't mean they won't
and that doesn't mean that I'm not fully
ready for it but you can't make it easy
and I think in many ways Trump did make
it easy for them to strike I think for
the this final portion of our
conversation we should shift to a
discussion of uh woke capitalism since
that's a big top recurring topic of your
campaign and your books uh the most
recent two uh at least and there's been
a lot of comments uh to that regard one
uh here says just FYI I'm not voting for
anyone whose platform includes waging a
war with wokism because your idea is
essentially based off censoring other
species
I mean I I can kind of speak to that
concern a little bit and yeah you can
respond to this because I live in Ron
DeSantis Florida and I've watched him
Advance things like the stop woke act
that's his attempt to stop uh wokeness
from encroaching into the schools and
into Corporate America and to my mind
the way it's been done here is a pretty
clear violation of free speech rights
it's it's pretty I don't understand this
is sloppy I think Rhonda said is a
sloppy because he doesn't have an
understanding of why he's doing what
he's doing I think that and it's a shame
that he has screwed this up in many ways
that have folks like yourselves maybe
and personal ask that question
understandably irritated when somebody
says they're fighting wokeness first of
all that's how I'm labeled I never
actually say that I'm waging a war on
wocus I say I want a crusade to revive a
missing national identity those are
different things that's what's me versus
Ron DeSantis is different is
a patrol yes and and I named that book
at a time where most people didn't know
what the word woke does and that work
was and it actually offers the most
rigorous definition of what we're
actually talking about that a bunch of
Republican puppets then take and run
with and bastardize what it actually
means and so yes I did I wrote the book
on it try reading the book and figure
and whoever asked the question
will have a very different impression
after reading that book yeah I have a
quick summary then of how uh battling
wokeness does not get the government
into policing what is and is not
permissible speech either in the public
sphere or in the in Corporate America so
that's the question to ask it's called
awoke Inc for a reason the ink part is
actually what's doing the work
so a lot of this is top-down government
driven in the first place that's what we
need to see that's what Ron DeSantis by
the way fails to see that's what I think
a lot of the people who are just going
through the motions of criticizing
wokeness fail to see let's talk about
woke capitalism ESG movement that's not
the free market that's an illusion don't
fall for the trick what's happening is
that the three largest asset managers in
the country BlackRock State Street and
Vanguard are using 20 trillion dollars
of citizens money
to foist those agendas onto corporate
boards I mean let's say apple I'll give
you some examples just to be you know
specific here because there's a specific
question of deserve specificity apple
and Home Depot did not want to adopt a
racial Equity audit until BlackRock and
State Street voted for it and then they
had to Chevron did not want to adopt a
scope 3 missions cap unless until
BlackRock State student Vanguard used
the money of everyday citizens without
their permission to vote for that
politicized policy they will say it's
about long-run investment return it's
not and I've written essay length and
book length works about why and I can
tell you why too but suffice to say that
everyone here will be persuaded that the
proponents and opponents of those
proposals and those boards themselves
agreed they had nothing to do with
advancing shareholder value it was about
advancing a social agenda so black
record states true to private companies
you might say why are they doing it well
here's why
blue States like California CalPERS in
the pension fund New York New York's
City comptroller and New York State
Pension funds say that they can't manage
their money unless they adopt firm-wide
commitments to the Paris climate Accords
which by the way the US did not sign up
to Trump pulled out of it Net Zero
standards by 2050 modern diversity
Equity inclusion standards that is not
the Invisible Hand of the free market
that is the invisible fist of government
which should make every libertarian's
blood boil so do not you they are they
are trying to use your language back
against you and I say your I mean strong
libertarian instincts used to call
myself one not that long ago right
they're weaponizing the language to dupe
you into thinking that this is the
evidence of the free market when in fact
it's lurking State action the entire
time I also tell conservatives I coach
them stop talking about big Tech
censorship
it's not it's government Tech censorship
because then government is using a
combination of threats and special
immunities and coordination to do
through the back door what government
couldn't do through the front door I
mean I think every libertarian should
have the hair on their back stand up to
know that the Biden White House
specifically calls and Executives from
say Twitter
to identify individual critics of the
government by name like Alex Berenson
and pressure them and ask them and
threaten them as to why they haven't
silenced that person which they then do
and get an attaboy on the back when they
do that's not the free market that is
State action in Disguise and if you need
a rhyme to help you if it's state action
and disguise the Constitution still
applies the Supreme Court has held that
on countless occasions from Bantam Books
where a prosecutor threatened a
bookstore owner to remove a book the
bookstore to remove the book Supreme
Court said that wasn't private action
that was State action to the railroads
and the War on Drugs actually there's a
case called Hanson where you know the
federal government wanted a way to War
on Drugs problem is we have a fourth
amendment in this country it's a good
thing well what they said is we'll wrap
a special form of immunity around those
railroads saying that those private
railroads can search whoever they want
that's just the action of a private
company and passengers can't sue them
Supreme Court said not so fast because
if they're using immunity as an
inducement to get a private company to
do what the government couldn't do then
that's lurking State action that's
exactly how section 230 works by the way
for internet companies and so back to
the original question oh oh yes so
section 230 is this is the analogous
form of the immunity that you wrap
around the railroad company by saying
that they can't be sued by a passenger
for violating their fourth amendment
rights the same thing is what section
230 C2 does people mix up C1 and C2 230
C2 what it says is even if there's a
political non-discrimination statute
like that Florida adopted for example
that that would be preempted by section
230 C2 and even if a citizen would have
otherwise been able to sue for the
removal or wrongful removal of
constitutionally protected speech or
suing of the or removal of their account
due to terms of service or whatever else
they can't because Federal Protection
section 230 C2 preempts it just like
that law of the railroads preempted a
passenger from being able to sue the
railroad okay seems like a stretch but
okay
so yeah certainly
I've just to give you a plug for your
book capitalist punishment is an
extensive look at the way that ESG is
kind of being worked through the system
but can I uh just very quickly before uh
Zach chimes in
um in that book you seem to be saying
more that it is the private actors uh it
is the BlackRock society and the
vanguards in the world that are pushing
this agenda through that's not is an
overly passive investors who have kind
of given up their rights for as
shareholders so I'm saying that it's
actually lurking State action that
guides BlackRock at State Street and
Vanguard to behave that way and other
conflicts of interest that they enjoy
even with State actors both in the U.S
and even in China that caused them to
Advocate on behalf of everyday citizens
using their money to do it it's a
complicated topic so you know we could
we could we could have a multi-hour
discussion or a book length work
explaining it but the reality is this
idea that it's just private actors
making decisions without government
intervention is a farce and I'll even
point to the Biden rule so Biden had a
pro-esg Department of Labor rule that
said its objective was to expressly
permit retirement fund managers to take
into account collateral benefits other
than investment return there was
initially a disclosure requirement to
retirees to let them know that's what
they were doing They removed the
disclosure requirement because they
purposefully wanted to make sure people
didn't know about it their stated
justification as they said that would
have a chilling effect on the use of ESG
factors but if you take something away
from this conversation it's from this
part of our conversation it's I think
the details matter right and so do I
think that this type of government
foisted woke capitalism esgism is a
problem I do but all I want is the
government actually to get out of the
way right which is different than
somebody like Ron DeSantis who doesn't
understand
the mechanics of anything that I've just
told you that thinks the right action is
somebody's behaving it's up to the State
of Florida we've got five minutes with
you left uh Vivek so uh Zach do you want
to ask uh yeah you know I the where I
get frustrated with how conservatives
talk about this generally is you know
this idea of lurking State action I
think is a good way to think about it I
agree with you that this is a problem
especially we've seen it on revealed
more and more with things like the
Twitter files the way that the lurking
State action is affecting the the
actions of private players where I get
frustrated is conservatives often then
take the action not to restrain the
state but to clamp down on the private
companies
section 230 and I've I've read your book
you know uh woke Inc uh and one of the
places where I I sort of saw this was
when you were talking about trying to
combat wokeness in the workplace
by by expanding employment protections
to uh People based on their political
beliefs so that a political belief would
be treated like great race or religion a
great topic for a Libertarian audience a
great topic it is a good debate to have
so so here's what I say
I would be totally fine and you find
another Republican to say this find
another libertarian politician to say
this and I'll give you a prize I would
be totally fine repealing the protected
classes okay I don't think we need them
I think I think that moment has passed I
don't think we need them however so long
as we have protected classes let me make
the case to you for lurking State action
here too for Viewpoint discrimination so
what happened is as long as you had race
and gender and sexual orientation now
included in gender post Bostock and
after the equality Act
what happened was courts interpreted
them so broadly to say that that doesn't
just prevent a business from
discriminating against an employee on
account of the race or their sex or
sexual orientation it also stops the
employer
from creating a hostile work environment
for a member of that protected class
it's illegal for an employer to create a
hostile work environment how does one
create a hostile work environment you
might ask well just look at the cases
that come before the alphabet soup of
the EEOC the equal employment
opportunity commission it includes
somebody wearing a red sweater a
grandmother wearing a red sweater on
Fridays to celebrate or support for U.S
troops that she was that a member of a
minority group said he found to be a
microaggression people are in the Hat of
the wrong presidential candidate I could
go on with examples
but what's the point I'm making the
existence of those protected classes
construed broadly
created the conditions for a Viewpoint
discrimination the government did while
leaving political viewpoints unprotected
so you can't have it both ways either we
get rid of the protected classes and
actually let the market work or you
correct for a negative externality of
actually having intervened in the market
creating government created Viewpoint
discrimination and then here's the funny
thing that a lot of people know it's
actually blue states that have
viewpoint-based discrimination
protections it's on the books in
California and even in limited senses in
other blue States because that was
actually during the bush era something
that they worried about in terms of
viewpoint discrimination in the private
sector in the other direction so again
here's where I think details matter and
you know the funny the funny part is I
probably have the deepest libertarian
instincts of anybody who's run for U.S
president in modern history but I'm
willing to actually go beyond I don't
believe in just reciting those pions
either I think we have to look at the
unique threats to Liberty as they
present themselves in the year 2023 and
so long as we have an unspoken consensus
that we're not allowed to go back and
look at the Civil Rights Act in 1964.
then let's get real about actually
addressing Liberty as it's experienced
by me you're right you're rank ordering
you're saying you would support the
elimination of the protected classes yes
but I will be honest that's not going to
happen it's not going to happen a
solution but in your mind it's actually
an improvement to expand the protected
classes in the absence of that that is
where you know I think there's room for
debate and questions but we're running
out of time on the stream so I'm gonna
leave uh it's a Nick to kind of wrap
wrap up with a final question I guess uh
you know uh I read capitalist punishment
um I've read Wok Inc and I find them
interesting
um I have this is a broader question
what is kind of what's your theory of
social change because it's clear that
America in most ways has gotten better
where you know we're a more tolerant
country we're a more Open Country uh Etc
but you know thinking about the Don
Lemon exchange and other things and
you've been critical of things like
black lives matter movements you're
critical of the government forcing
corporations to do certain things you're
critical of Corporations Express
assessing political commitments or
cultural commitments that may or may not
be at odds with their bottom lines or
whatever but you know you you very much
emphatically followed Milton Friedman on
the idea that you know the the primary
or the only function of a corporation is
to increase shareholder value we have a
great early 2000s debate with Milton
Friedman John Mackey of Whole Foods and
uh TJ Rogers formerly the CEO of Cypress
semiconductor but I guess what I'm
asking is what what's your theory of
social change is it fundamentally
political is it cultural is it economic
is it technological
um you know and I I in thinking about
this and going back to that immigration
question which I come back to a lot in
the early 20s as immigration was being
restricted pretty much everywhere in the
world there was a famous case where in a
man from India who had served in World
War one uh and had become a citizen or
tried to become a citizen it went all
the way to the Supreme Court and it was
ruled that people people from India
could not be Americans they could not be
naturalized citizens they couldn't move
here legally uh and that wasn't fixed
until 1946. now you know how does that
happen how how do we protest how do we
change how do we make Society more the
way that we want it to be and obviously
what that is changes what is your theory
ultimately of social change because
sometimes it seems like you're attacking
political change or technological change
or cultural change or commercial
activity how you know what what's the
best way for America to you know find
what that national identity is it's a
great question this is this is the
conversation we need to be having across
the country because I don't think it
should just be top down I think the role
of a president in driving that change is
to set a national example I think Ronald
Reagan is the last president who did
that well I think we can't just preach
about family values I mean the person we
elect in the White House Is Not A Robot
it's not an automaton it's a human being
and I think setting that National
example I think is underappreciated as a
lever for driving positive social change
in a way that doesn't require violating
anybody's principles or political
convictions and I think that that's a
missed opportunity in this country in
the last eight years certainly a badly
missed opportunity at a time where we
could have used
a fulfillment of our hunger for purpose
and meaning and even the examples of
leadership that set I think it's also
going to require people stepping up then
and responding to that example in ways
that cause parents to step up in the way
they take responsibility for raising
their kids Business Leaders to step up
and say my goal the way you create
shareholder value is to have a worthy
Mission and to stick to that mission
rather than to be brow beaten into
orthogonal objectives in their own
capacities not because the government
brow beats them into doing it that's
where Rhonda Santos and I are different
but because they choose to do that
through their own inspiration and
self-discovery as part of a process of
cultural change and then if there's a
government as is the case today that
actually brow beats them in the other
direction the role of actually a good
version of a government leader is to
remove that I would say artificial State
guidance that invisible Fist of the big
government so I think that my theory of
social changes these things are best
delivered bottom up
I think the role of the government is to
get out of the way but we can't assume
that the status quo is starting at some
sort of neutral white slate and in in
very great discussion I've had you guys
really enjoyed it that's why I I no
longer that's one of the reasons I no
longer call myself a Libertarian is that
I find that many people who do like to
wish a status quo that isn't a status
quo we're starting with all kinds of
complicated lurking State action that we
can't wish away it is what it is and
we're starting in the present correcting
that is going to take I think more than
just recitations to pions we memorized
40 years ago because that's not the
world as it exists today and that's what
I think a leader in the white house
needs to understand is staying true to
those principles but also you know one
of the things that I've said for example
I would do and this relates to you know
point you raised earlier one of my
executive orders on day one will be any
time there has been a government
bureaucrat in the last five years we
could say 10 years but practically we'll
say five years
who has pressured a private actor to
take an action that the government
couldn't have otherwise taken we have to
publish that we have to at least see it
it's called the Twitter files called the
state action files
and I think that that's neither a
violation of is that an overreach of
government Authority no we're talking
about making transparent
the misdeeds of the government itself
and so you call that a war on
bureaucracy a war on wokeness who cares
what you label it I think you've got to
stay true to the principle of
understanding that the threats to
Liberty did originate many of them the
ones I'm concerned with certainly with
government overreach be it blue State
Pension funds in California or be it our
federal government but let go of the
labels that we use whether you call that
conservative or libertarian stay true to
that principle and that goes to the
heart of national identity itself
because we're a nation founded on those
principles and that's what I'm leading
both through my policy agenda if you go
deep enough to understand what the
principles that actually underlie it
versus the surface level comparisons to
Trump or DeSantis and then also
hopefully the the personal first
personal example with which you know
it's the standard that the people of
this country you all included should
hold me to in leading the country if I'm
elected and so you know I think that
there's a lot there but I think that the
combination of the example you set and
and getting the government out of the
way is the full extent of what the
government leadership jobs ought to be
and that should be enough to pave the
way for other leaders and other spheres
of our culture having nothing to do with
government to actually Step Up and Drive
what you call positive social change so
it's a great question to end on and I
appreciate it thank you yeah
give a dollar so that's what that's my
my cheap ask at the end but but I
promise you I will Elevate these issues
starting in August on the Republican
debate stage and I hope they'll be good
for the country all right Vivek
ramaswami the latest book is capitalist
punishment uh you're running for
president thanks so much for spending
the time with us thanks guys we'll see
you